bonjour à tous aujourd'hui une petite
vidéo rapide pour vous parler d'un jeu
très à la mode qui s'appelle wordle et
qui passionne les foules sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est un jeu qu'on peut jouer
sur une nappe ou sur un site web et il
s'agit de deviner un mot en le moins
d'essais possible et aujourd'hui on va
voir comment jouer de façon optimale à
ce jeu grâce aux maths et à la
programmation dans le principe du jeu
est simple dans sa version d'origine qui
est en anglais on doit deviner un mot de
cinq lettres en faisant des propositions
et à chaque proposition le jeu nous dit
qu'elles sont les lettres qui sont
bonnes en verre quelles sont celles qui
sont bonnes mais mal placée en jaune et
quelles sont celles qui n'apparaissent
pas du tout en gris et on essaye de
découvrir le mot en le moins d'essais
possible très simple certains
reconnaîtront là d'ailleurs le principe
du jeu motus ou encore du master mind
pour les moins jeunes et il ya
évidemment des versions en français ce
qui fait la popularité de ce jeu c'est
qu'il n'ya qu'un mot par jour le même
pour tout le monde et qu'on peut
partager sa grille de résultat sur les
réseaux sociaux moi ce patron motifs
mais dont je peux comprendre alors
comment faire pour être bon à ce jeu là
effectivement vous sentez qu'il faut pas
procéder n'importe comment c'est comme
au pendu on va essayer de jouer des
coups intéressants pour converger le
plus vite possible vers la solution un
point notable des règles c'est qu'on
peut très bien jouer des mots dont on
sait pertinemment qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être la bonne réponse mais qu'on va
essayer dans l'optique d'éliminer un
maximum de possibilités et moi comme ça
me fatigue de réfléchir j'ai essayé de
faire les calculs et d'automatiser tout
ça avec un algorithme et pour faire ça
de façon optimale il faut qu'on arrive à
quantifier cette idée d'éliminer un
maximum de possibilités
pour en parler prenons un jeu avec
lequel vous êtes certainement familier
le jeu de société qui s dans ce jeu on
cherche à identifier un personnage parmi
24 possibilité en posant des questions
sur son apparence physique et
l'adversaire doit nous répondre par oui
ou non mais comment on fait pour trouver
les meilleures questions
prenons un exemple imaginons que sur les
24 personnages la moitié est un chapeau
et puis seulement 3 et des lunettes on
peut par exemple demander est ce que mon
personnage a un chapeau
bien est-ce que mon personnage a des
lunettes mais par exemple laquelle de
ces deux questions et la plus utile si
je pose la question chapeau je suis sûr
qu'à la fin je n'aurai plus que 12
possibilité puisque il ya douze suspects
dans les deux catégories donc je vais à
coup sûr pas mal progressé si je pose la
question lunettes c'est un peu à double
tranchant si la réponse est oui alors là
j'ai vachement progressé il n'y a plus
que trois suspects mais si la réponse
est non et bien je n'aurais pas appris
grand chose donc bah c'est un peu risqué
pour faire le bon choix il faut arriver
à quantifier cette idée de quelle
quantité d'informations je peux espérer
acquérir en posant telle ou telle
question et il va y avoir évidemment une
notion de probabilités parce que je ne
sais pas à l'avancé ce qu'on va me
répondre pour illustrer cette
quantification je vais prendre un jeu
encore plus simple je pense à un nombre
et vous devez deviner lequel en me
faisant des propositions et moi je vous
réponds juste plus grand ou plus petit
et puis on fait ça plusieurs fois de
suite jusqu'à ce que le goût de vignes
et alors on va se fixer un intervalle
évidemment je vais penser à un nombre
entre 0 et 127 qu'est ce que vous ne
faites comme propositions pour essayer
de deviner on retrouve le même dilemme
co qui s intuitivement si on tape au
milieu qu'on propose 64 on est certain
qu'il ne restera que 64 possibilité si
c'est plus petit ce sera entre 0 et 63
et puis si c'est plus grands 2,64 à 127
mais on pourrait aussi la joie est
risqué imaginons que vous me proposiez
10 si je vous réponds en dessous voilà
vous avez vachement réduit le truc a par
contre si c'est au dessus vous n'êtes
pas très avancé en moyenne ça fait quoi
eh ben pour le savoir on va faire un peu
d'écriture binaire l'écriture binaire
c'est une manière d'écrire les nombres
avec juste des 0 et des 1
001 c12
c103 c'est un 1/4 c100 etc pour
reconstituer un nombre à partir de son
écriture binaire on prend chaque chiffre
qu'on appelle ça un mythe et pour le
premier en partant de la droite on
associe un le deuxième 2 le troisième 4
le quatrième 8 et ainsi de suite on fait
toutes les puissances de 2 pourrait
faire un nom dans 3 0 et 127 on a besoin
que de sept buts à zéro c'est que des
zéros 127 ce sera que des 1
et par exemple l'écriture 1 0 à 1 001
représente le nombre 64 +16 plus 8 + 1
c'est-à-dire 89 alors pourquoi je vous
parle de cette écriture binaire si pour
le premier coup vous choisissez la
stratégie je tape au milieu c'est à dire
que vous me proposez 64 eh bien je vais
vous dire si c'est plus grand ou plus
petit et en faisant ça en fait ça
revient exactement à vous révéler le
premier bits de l'écriture binaire du
nombreux mystères les nombres plus grand
que 64 commencent tous par 1 1 et ce
plus petit commencent tous par 1 0 donc
choisir de proposer 64 en fait c'est
complètement équivalent a directement
demandé la valeur du premier bits du
nombre à deviner bon maintenant
imaginons que je vous réponde que c'est
plus grands le premier but est à 1 vous
savez que la réponse se trouve entre 64
et 127 est à nouveau vous pouvez taper
au milieu et me proposait 96 et en vous
répondant si c'est plus grand ou plus
petit que 96 en fait je ne fais que vous
révéler la valeur du deuxième but de
l'écriture binaire et ainsi de suite
donc tapé au milieu c'est à dire réduire
de moitié le nombre de possibilités
c'est complètement équivalent à acquérir
un bit d'information sur le nombre et on
va utiliser cette notion pour quantifier
nos progrès notre unité d'information
acquise ce sera le bit
imaginons que dès le début du jeu je
vous ai fait une fleur et je vous ai dit
où en fait le nombre il est entre 64 et
96 il y avait cent vingt-huit
possibilité au départ y en a plus que 32
j'ai réduit d'un facteur 4 le nombre de
possibilités et ça c'est équivalent à
vous révéler les deux bits d'information
les deux premiers du nombreux mystères
ici ce sera 1 0 et on peut généraliser
cette idée si je réduis l'intervalle
d'un facteur 8 ça revient à acquérir
trois bits d'information d'un facteur
16,4 bit9 acteurs 32 5 buts et c'est
bien et si j'aurais dû d'un facteur 12
eh ben on sent que c'est quelque part
entre 3 et 4 bits d'information mais
combien exactement eh bien on peut
mettre tout ça dans une formule en
utilisant ce qu'on appelle le logarithme
binaire alors je vous passe les détails
mais s'il ne vous reste qu'une fraction
x de vos possibilités initial et bien
l'information acquise par cette
opération c'est moins locke de 2 x ép
une réduction d'un douzième ses environs
3,58
maintenant qu'on a cette notion de
quantité d'informations acquise en
fonction de la réduction des
possibilités on va pouvoir chercher de
façon quantitative quelle est la
stratégie optimale
si je tape au milieu on l'a dit on a
deux possibilités au dessus et en
dessous et chacune correspond à une
réduction de moitié donc un bit
d'information dans les deux cas non
facile et si je prends un risque que je
choisi de taper à 10 à 6 c en dessous
bingo j'ai réduit mes possibilités d'un
facteur 12 et quelques je gagne 3,6 bits
d'information pas mal par contre si
c'est au-dessus il me reste 118
possibilité sur les 128 de départ ça
fait seulement 0,1 bits d'information
acquise
donc si je choisis dix on a deux issues
possibles une très intéressante et puis
l'autre pas du tout et pour juger de
l'ensemble on va t'on d'airé par la
probabilité il n'y a que 10 chance sur
cent vingt-huit que je tombe dans le cas
favorable et 118 chance sur cent
vingt-huit que ce soit le cas
défavorable et en moyenne et bien ça
fait environ 0 point 4 bits
d'information acquise avec cette
stratégie risque et donc en moyenne la
stratégie risquée proposé 10 est moins
intéressante que la stratégie taper au
milieu bien sûr c'est une moyenne donc
si on tape au milieu on gagne un beat à
coup sûr et puis si on choisit 10 on a
une petite chance de gagner 3,6 vite
mais bon elle est petite la chance on
peut facilement tracé la courbe pour
tous les choix et voir que dans ce
problème simple la stratégie optimale
celle qui maximise l'information moyenne
acquise eh ben c'est bien de taper au
milieu bien maintenant revenons à warden
le problème qu'on doit résoudre est
assez similaire mais avec pas mal de
complexité additionnel cette fois on
doit choisir un mot et on a des milliers
de possibilités donc ce qu'on veut
savoir c'est quelle est le mot optimale
celui qui va réduire le plus l'espace
des suspects si on veut celui qui va
nous apporter le plus d'informations
le souci c'est que ce que nous répond le
jeu ça n'est pas juste plus grand ou
plus petit c'est une séquence de cinq
symboles de couleur gris jaune ou vert
donc pour chaque mot qu'on peut proposer
il n'y a pas juste deux possibilités à
considérer mais tout un tas trois
puissances 5 pour être précis ça fait
deux 143 cas mais on peut faire la même
chose pour chaque mot qu'on pourrait
proposer on considère chacune des deux
cent quarante trois réponses possibles
qu'on va nous faire et on regarde de
combien se réduire l espace des
possibilités dans chacun de ses 243 cas
et puis on fait la moyenne de
l'information acquise on fait ça pour
tous les maux possibles jusqu'à trouver
le mot qui rapporte le plus ça paraît un
peu compliquée un message programme très
bien et il ya besoin d'aller un peu vite
donc j'ai fait ça en c++ et je me suis
reprogrammer un petit jeu de wardle pour
tester tout ça pour ça j'avais besoin
d'une grande liste de mots j'ai utilisé
le site lexique point org qui fournit
une base de données avec des mesures de
fréquence est donc ici je vais vous
montrer avec des mots de 5,4 et j'ai
gardé seulement les plus fréquents j'ai
pris les 4096 premier alors pourquoi
4096 vous allez me dire c'est bien 4096
ces deux puissances 12 donc si je
choisis un mot au pif à vous faire
deviner si je veux vous le révéler
entièrement et bien je dois vous donner
son numéro 1 par exemple le numéro 1548
et ce numéro est bien il faut 12 bits
pour l'écrire en binaire au début de la
partie vous ignorez lequel de ces 4096
mo et le bon donc votre ignorance et de
12 bits et au fur et à mesure que la
partie va avancer les possibilités vont
diminuer votre ignorance va se réduire
et à chaque étape vous allez acquérir de
l'information le plus dur c'est le
premier coup on sait strictement rien et
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est chercher le
mot optimale d'ouverture celui qui en
moyenne apporte le plus d'informations
possibles alors j'ai fait tourner mon
code et la relance hambourg et bien
parmi tous les mots de ma base le
meilleur s'est tarie t am i et
encombrants pourquoi il ya des lettres
fréquentes trois voyelles pas de
répétition ça paraît pas mal donc si
vous jouez à wardle en français avec
cinq lettres par mola meilleure
ouverture c'est tard en moyenne j'ai
calculé que cette ouverture va vous
apporter à peu près 6 bits d'information
civique d'information ça correspond à
une réduction jusqu'à seulement une
soixantaine de possibilités au lieu des
quatre mille et quelques qu'on avait au
départ on s'est pas mal évidemment
n'oubliez pas si vite c'est une moyenne
dont vous pouvez très bien ne pas avoir
de chance et qu'il reste plus de
possibilités que ça inversement le jour
où j'ai déterminé ce mot je suis allé
sur un équivalent français de wordle
pour tester et ce jour là et bien j'ai
eu un bal monstrueux parce que le moi
deviner c'était tarifs ben ouais ça peut
arriver or une fois qu'on a joué le
premier coup l'espace des possibilités
s'est restreint et on peut calculer
l'information effectivement acquise par
ce coup et l'a comparé aussi vite qu'on
espérait obtenir et on se retrouve
ensuite dans une situation similaire le
problème reste globalement le même mais
sur un espace des possibilités beaucoup
plus restreint quel est le mot qui va
nous en apprendre le plus et là c'est
pas comme au premier coup il n'y a pas
une réponse universelle ça va dépendre
de ce qu'on a eu au premier coup mais on
peut refaire la même chose on calcule la
moyenne de l'information qu'on espère
acquérir pour chacune des possibilités
et on choisit le meilleur mot et ainsi
de suite j'ai programmé tout ça et j'ai
testé sur des parties de wardle avec des
mots à deviner le tirés au sort et quand
ça tourne eh bien on voit qu'à chaque
étape les possibilités se réduisent les
12 bits d'incertitude initial se
convertissent peu à peu en bits
d'information et avec cette technique
automatique et bien on arrive à résoudre
sans problème en trois à quatre coups en
moyenne ce qui est considéré comme une
bonne performance
évidemment ça ruine complètement
l'intérêt du jeu mais moi je trouve ça
plus fun de coder un algo qui résout que
de vraiment jouer au jeu chacun son truc
un juge est pas
[Musique]
j'ai pas poussé le truc plus loin mais
notez qu'en pratique sur les vrais
partis on peut faire un peu mieux si on
tient compte du fait que les mots à
trouver ne sont en général pas parmi les
plus rares par exemple dans mon
échantillon de 4096 mo j'ai des trucs
comme gamme et zebra argon et on peut
faire l'hypothèse qu'ils ne font pas
partie des solutions que possible ça
empêche pas de les utiliser pour essayer
de gagner de l'information mais en
pratique par exemple si après deux coups
dans l'ensemble des possibilités il ne
vous reste plus que tapie t'as pas un
tamis tanins est atteint vous pouvez
peut-être tenter directement votre
chance avec tapis le mot le plus courant
plutôt que de chercher un truc qui
serait plus optimale du point de vue de
l'information à acquérir mais qui en
fait a peu de chances d'être la solution
pour prendre une analogie sportif si
vous jouez au tennis vous n'essayez pas
de marquer le point à chaque frappe de
balle vous préparez le truc et puis
quand c'est bon vous tapez pour marquer
eh bien là c'est pareil optimiser le
gain d'information c'est des coûts de
préparation et à vous de voir à quel
moment il faut arrêter et puis ajouté
si vous voulez creuser cette piste la
chaîne sky blue one born a fait une
super vidéo où il implémente un
algorithme du même genre dont lucie des
pythons mais ça change pas grand chose
et il discute justement des
améliorations intéressantes sur cette
notion de préparer versus eux tenter sa
chance pour marquer comme toujours avec
lui la vidéo de cybergun est vraiment
génial c'est lui qui m'a donné envie
d'essayer de l'implémenter arnaud tour
et puis bah de façon générale je peux
dire c'est de toute façon de la chaîne
de vulgarisation préférées toutes
catégories confondues j'ai vraiment
énormément d'admiration pour ce qu'il
fait donc si vous comprenez l'anglais
foncez voir voilà c'est tout pour cette
petite vidéo impromptue je mettrais
peut-être le code à disposition si
j'arrive à le nettoyer dit c'est là
parce que là c'est vraiment hyper crade
et puis on se retrouve très bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo